glenn greenwald one of the seven
journalists
i believe i said there were seven
journalists left i
i may be exaggerating that number but
you're one of them
thank you for talking to us i appreciate
it from your beautiful mountainside
uh casita in i don't know in brazil i'm
i'm unsure
um i wanted to that's so multi-lingual
yeah well i try i wanted to talk to you
um first kind of a broad general
question
are you surprised at how controversial
you've become over the last 12 months
is it is it shocking to you how many
people are angry at you and how often
they're angry
not exactly i mean i do tend to have a
very slightly polarizing personality
and it's kind of been that way for a
long time
so making people angry isn't
totally new to me i've
been doing that more or less since i
started writing about politics and even
before when i was practicing on
manhattan
and even before that when i was just an
obnoxious kid
but i think what has happened is because
of this perception it's not the reality
but the perception
that i have removed myself from
one faction and place myself into
another
what generally inspires the most intense
anger and hatred are not people who are
just against you from the start but
people who you
believe have become traitors to the
cause or heretics to the religion
and there's a lot of people who are
looking at me that way and are really
angry it's kind of like a sense of
betrayal and i think that's part of what
is being generated but i also think it's
you know i mean i don't want to act like
i'm some innocent victim i mean i also
especially since i left the intercept
and found this kind of
you know complete freedom and
independence
have been waging my own little war on a
dominant sector of the media and it's
only
natural to expect that they're going to
wage war back on me
so i feel like it's kind of a two-sided
battle and it's not just me
standing there all alone and innocent
being you know attacked what in your
estimation has
changed um the media held a lot of water
for george w bush
well can you kill them i'm kidding um
i mean i hate i mean animals are so i
know he loves dogs but it's just
it's it's i mean it's amazing the these
people with the dogs all the time dogs
you have to
hey you have to take it on the right way
tim they're very they're as excited as i
am about
your show i was actually supposed to be
on rogan tomorrow and i had to cancel
that
who's that their little is that about
that as well who is that does he have a
podcast go ahead
anyway i've rogan oh yeah the guy for
fear factor
anyway um what has happened in your
estimation
with mainstream media because they did
hold a lot of water for george w
bush they seem to always uh covet their
position
coddling people in power this is my my
view of it as a comedian
and i i look at them and i say they like
to be close to power they depe
they depend on scoops and they depend on
access for stories
and i've watched you know i i it's
amazing in my own
short little meaningless life i have
watched ann coulter go from
let's invade their countries kill their
leaders and convert them to christianity
too
we shouldn't be uh doing anything we
have to be america first and take care
of our own
and i've watched rachel maddow go from
um
we should not be uh you know using the
military as a tool
uh of uh foreign intervention
to we need to be using the military it's
everybody's flip-flop values seem to
mean nothing
and the only thing that seems to matter
is this raw lust
for viewers or for power what has
changed
in this last you know five years
so the attribute of the media that you
identified at the start of that question
which was this kind of deference to
power has been there for a long time
it's probably more than anything else
what caused me to stop practicing law
and start writing about politics in 2005
was my observation that the media had
become extremely deferential to bush and
cheney and the war on terror as you said
it was a bipartisan war on terror
there was very little dissent tolerated
no questioning and there were
all these kind of vital issues
especially attacks on civil liberties
being
waged in the name of uh fighting
terrorism that i thought were very
disturbing grave that very few people
are covering and i started writing about
politics in order to do that and noticed
of course that the media
was deferential to the cia the security
state that goes back to the cold war as
well
so i don't think i still think that's a
huge pathology in media but i don't
think it's new
i think what's new is what happened
during the trump years which is in a lot
of ways donald trump just broke
the brains of huge numbers huge sectors
of
american society think about it if you
actually believe
and you tell yourself every day and the
people that you work with and listen to
and who are around you are also
affirming this list
of really disturbing conspiracies like
the kremlin has taken over the united
states and is controlling the levers of
power
using sexual and financial blackmail
over the white house
that donald trump is like this hilar
hitlerian figure
who's ushering in fascism and is an
existential threat to america if you
actually start
believing all those things and saying
them every day you're going to go
[ __ ] crazy
and not only are you going to go [ __ ]
crazy but you're going to start to
conclude
that a whole variety of things that
previously were unthinkable to you
because they're unethical or way outside
of what the role is of the profession
that you've chosen now become not only
acceptable but
urgent so the idea that you have to do
anything and say anything in order to
stop this
uniquely insidious figure
you have to align with the cia and the
fbi
and the nsa the agencies devoted to
killing donald trump you have to
are undermining donald trump you have to
reunite with the neocons and bush cheney
scumbags because they're also against
donald trump
it just it radically reshaped the world
view of
financial elites media elites political
elites and donald trump became the
singular
figure through which everybody or almost
everybody
understood the world and that's what i
think accounts for those reversals that
you were just alluding to
what about trump was if jeb bush had won
i don't think we would have had this
so what about trump was
the the you know the catalyst
for such a widespread mental breakdown
was it that he was vulgar
and crass was it that so many people had
told themselves he wasn't gonna win
uh was it that he defeated potentially
the first woman
president what about him specifically
uh sent people down that rabbit hole
yeah so i think it was all of those
things that you just mentioned but i do
think the primary one
is that just compartmentally trump
was such a radical deviation from what
we've come to expect from the face of
american power
if you actually look at what the trump
administration did
there's almost nothing that it did that
is radical from the perspective of the
american political tradition
there was very little convergence
between the things he was saying and
tweeting
that made people so upset and the things
that the united states government
was actually doing because the whole
point of the us government in the
post-world war ii order
is to function outside of the
constraints of democratic accountability
they've insulated themselves from
elections it doesn't matter who wins
there's no way to change who they are
unless you devote yourself in like a
kind of very devoted war-like
fashion to undermining them which is way
beyond trump's competence or
desire he you know had the attention
span of a gnat
he was you know interested in using the
office just to like vindicate petty
personal grievances not to radically
transform the country which had its
value but
so yeah i think it was what you know
what american presidents really are
expected to do more than anything
is to be a deceit a deceitful
prettifying
symbol on the horrors of american power
american capitalism and american
imperialism they're supposed to
be these like erudite lofty noble
figures like obama and even like bush
was and he's like evangelical
incarnation
to put a pretty face on what the united
states is and trump not only was
incapable of doing that
he's just a bulgarian right he's like
spent his life in
you know as a billionaire or a he says
yeah he's a thrice
man he's a thrice married gambling
tycoon i mean this
is not the person you'd want
representing your team
right but not only did they have no
ability to do it but he also had no
desire to do it you know i think like
one of the most telling moments was
early on he did an interview with bill
o'reilly
on fox and bill o'reilly said you seem
really
positive and enthusiastic about putin
what like how can you feel so positive
about putin when he kills
journalists and dissidents and trump
said what you don't think we
have a lot of people here yeah his quote
we kill a lot of people here too
yeah right and as usual the thing that
makes everybody angriest is when you
tell the
the forbidden truth right like everybody
knows that that's true
right but the american president is the
last person who's supposed to say that
right they're supposed to uphold images
of
american exceptionalism so i think it
was just the upset
that it burno he just kind of like
defecated on the white house he like
vandalized the
noble corridors of power right that
stand for american exceptionalism and i
think that more than anything is what
got them so upset along with the
uncertainty that
you know it kind of [ __ ] with
everybody's expectations the new york
times was saying there was a 97
chance that hillary clinton was going to
be elected she's like a
you know inside member of the royal
court and has been for decades there was
the historical aspect of the first woman
president although
those other things you said that also
caused it but he was just such an
unpredictable tornado you know
sweeping through washington where they
all their power and their certainty and
their
money and their livelihoods are all
based that it was just like an
earthquake
why didn't they why didn't they upset
them why didn't they kill them
right because they killed jfk they kill
certain people certain people they don't
kill they control
um why would they not
in this case kill him i mean maybe they
can't anymore
in the 60s they used to kill everybody
uh now they
i mean bobby uh kennedy martin luther
king i mean you can
go through them right malcolm x i mean
they should kill a lot of people right
now i guess they couldn't do that in
this case he won the presidency
um so do do you think when you had james
brennan and clapper and all these
people that were working
to you know undermine his presidency
seemingly from before he was even
inaugurated
um do you think would you say that was
sort of
a um am i am i going too far to say that
that was
uh kind of a soft coup were they trying
to manufacture intelligence
that got the president impeached and
potentially removed
was this based on anything real was it
paranoia i mean i read the steele
dossier and i've read
some of jane mayer's reporting and i i
used to like jane mayer a lot like
she wrote a great book about torture
called the dark side
um and i think she's she's written some
some really good stuff she wrote about
the coke family
but some of her reporting on the russian
stuff seemed a little paranoid
what what do you think that was when you
look at russiagate you look at the
inception of it where did it come from
is this is this paranoia or was this a
coordinated attempt
to to remove uh a guy who is elected
from office
well you know what's interesting we're
filming we're we're taping this on
on the 50th birthday of julian assange
who yes i
was going to ask you about this yes you
might say like well why don't they just
kill him
because he has been you know probably
the single most effective person in
terms of spilling
western secrets in the last generation
and the reason is is because they didn't
have to they just neutralized him they
kept him locked away in pradorian
embassy for eight years and now they
have him in a high security
prison in the uk never having charged
him with any or convicted him of any
crime but just he's been in prison for a
decade
that's how i look at trump as well he
was really a weak president to him like
right he he dominated the news
but they did a great job with this
concocted russiagate
scandal that really engulfed his
presidency for four years he got
impeached
twice i mean the second time was because
of the january 6 stuff but
you know the first impeachment grew out
of russia gate but it paralyzed the
administration forever they were under
investigation from the start
and that all came out of the cia and the
fbi and you know like it's not like it
was completely concocted
i mean i know this is shocking to a lot
of people but
countries do interfere in each other's
domestic politics in the united states
more so than anybody so yeah the
russians wanted to [ __ ] with
the election just like the iranians did
just like the ukrainians did on behalf
of
of uh hillary clinton and
you know there were some meetings
between the trump campaign and the
russians that ordinarily would have just
faded into the woodwork and the context
of like billions of dollars
poured into the election some russian
bots on twitter and facebook were like
an
infinitesimal barely detectable presence
so
they took this tiny little grain of
truth and they
exploded it into this completely
manufactured but quite dangerous
conspiracy theory because it ratcheted
up tensions between the world's two
largest nuclear powers and then you had
these media outlets who as i said before
were convinced that it was their solemn
duty no longer to do journalism but to
stop trump which are two very different
things
and they just started getting fed by the
cia like they have been for decades
this this this this just carousel of
leaks
designed to harm trump and they just
were publishing it without any critical
analysis at all right so when you say
like why did they kill trump like they
didn't need to kill trump
they got most of what they wanted
despite trump
they why why couldn't they control the
way that john brennan kind of controlled
obama it was a very close relationship
and got
obama i think we were in seven wars and
we you know had a huge
uh drone war why were they not able to
do that with trump was it mainly
personality or did they
they felt that they had to neutralize
him with russiagate why would they not
just he seems like a guy that loves
adulation
he seems like a guy could was there no
other way
that they could have um you know exactly
influence on him besides
you know dragging the country through
this two-year somewhat ridiculous thing
so part of it i do think is personality
if you look at how obama has navigated
through life he's always been an
institutionalist he always appeased
institutional power
he was very adept at um making people
feel like if they connected to him that
they were doing something subversive and
important when in reality all he was
doing was aggrandizing
institutions of authority that's who
obama was so he came into office
with his huge army behind him saying he
was going to change washington he had no
interest in doing that so it was very
easy to
kind of uh mold obama and integrate him
into this
existing permanent power center he
didn't really resist he kind of liked
that he found it appealing
so you know and he got those like
cerebral generals like david petraeus
like special forces and like covert
operations more than
full-scale invasions so you know they
were very happy with obama
um i think it's two things with trump
one is i do think like his personality
you know
if you look at how trump has always
lived his life i lived in new york 15
years when trump was you know
just like a celebrity billionaire real
estate local always on page six or
whatever
you know he was born in queens we always
had like this huge inferiority complex
he always felt
justifiably like the manhattan
establishment looked down their noses at
him because of how he spoke his outer
burrow demeanor
that's why he was building those huge
you know penises in the middle of
manhattan to show that like he wanted to
live above them all he like i always had
an inferiority complex
much like richard nixon did and so when
you have this inferiority complex it
breeds this like resentment
and when you're resentful toward
institutions you're really not looking
for them to
like you you actually feel this
hostility towards them because you know
that they look down upon you that's one
thing but i think the bigger part of it
was
the cia and fbi's maneuvering against
trump began
prior to his inauguration it happened
throughout the 2016 campaign that was
when russia gate was born
in order to help hillary they were
openly cheering for hillary
but the last two prior cia directors
michael hayden under george
bush michael morell under obama so one
republican one democrat both
essentially endorsed hillary and the new
york times and the washington post
both accused trump of being a russian
agent so this narrative came from the
cia
and trump knew that they were trying to
sabotage him from winning so as soon as
he won
the first thing he did was he turned
around and [ __ ] the cia and then like
remember one of the first things that
they did was james comey
went to you know the trump tower and
briefed
trump on the steele dossier knowing that
that would then justify news outlets
covering it and that was before he was
even inaugurated
so he was at war with them from the
start and they were at war with him
and i think like one of the most telling
exchanges people should go google this
if you they haven't seen it because it's
like a rosetta stone for how american
politics works
trump being trump when he saw that the
cia was trying to blame russia
for his victory which he felt you know
like it was kind of undermining
or delegitimizing what he had achieved
so he was very angry about it started
going on twitter and mocking them for
getting a rock
wrong like why the [ __ ] should we
believe the cia when they say russia did
it when they're the idiots who told us
that weapons of mass destruction still
not had weapons of mass destruction
again things that american presidents
don't say that are nonetheless true
and i think it was like three days
before trump was inaugurated chuck
schumer
the senior democrat in washington went
on the rachel maddow show
and she asked him about these tweets
that trump was she was very upset
because she loves the cia
she's very upset that trump would like
demean you know the brave men and women
at the cia who keep us safe and she
asked humor about it
schumer said leaving aside the morality
of it
he thinks he's a hard-nosed businessman
but even for a hard notice
just as a hard-nosed businessman it's
such a stupid thing what he's doing
because everyone in washington knows
that if you [ __ ] with the cia they have
six different ways to sunday to get back
at you
and that's what they're going to do to
him he foretold the entire
as you said right like he openly
admitted what you're not supposed to
acknowledge
most people don't really know what the
cia is or what they do i mean my
listeners do and
you know i think it's most people think
the cia goes around you know
keeping uh terrorists from flying planes
into buildings which i'm sure
it is a percentage of their job but from
my understanding
the cia is a kind of the enforcement arm
of the larger uh whatever you want to
call it whether it's the
military-industrial complex some people
have said it's that you know they use
the word deep state
basically these unelected power factions
in washington that are made up of this
revolving door
of corporatists and lobbyists and
defense contractors and people that are
involved in the extraction of natural
resources and uh
you know high-level people uh in banking
and high-level people in tech
and the cia is sort of um you know their
their muscle
so to speak it's they're the agency
that's able to kind of
pave the way for them to do the things
that they want to do
is am i wrong in my conception of what
the cia does and what their
what their function is you know maybe
their primary function
no it's it's pretty accurate i mean you
know i like if anyone ever asked me what
book should i read
to understand american politics i always
encourage them to read
any history of post-world war the
post-world war ii national security
state like the devil's chessboard
yeah it's great an amazing book you know
because it's uh the other one that's
good is um
um um are you there vodka it's me
chelsea by chelsea handler
where she lays out the role of nation
states in the post-cold war paradigm
but my favorite foreign relations
scholars so
she knows more about espionage for
someone that spent
as long as she did drinking margaritas
she knows a lot about russian politics
and a lot about espionage
and i commit as too many people in my
business many people who've spent their
lives talking about their penises on
stage
uh are very good at counter-espionage i
had no idea counter-intelligence they're
very good at it
um you know god bless them what's
do you look at that as somebody you know
you participate in the country
and you see hollywood and you know
what's going on does
what is i mean i tend to think it is
because trump was kind of a creation of
hollywood
and they felt like like you said in the
beginning when you turn your back on
someone when it comes from within it's
much harder to accept
than when someone's always been outside
of that sphere but trump is a creation
of hollywood he was a hollywood
star the biggest reality tv show of his
era
you know uh but when you see people
doing your job
you're a foreign affairs correspondent
to you know or an investigative report
or whatever you want to call yourself
when you see people doing that on
twitter who have zero credentials
and they are you know actors actresses
comedians even some people calling
themselves journalists you're
you have taken real risks like you live
in brazil because of the stories you've
broken
what do you how do you deal with that
does that enrage you do you think that's
funny well you know it's
what's interesting is i think i started
i think it i was trying to remember the
trajectory of like my
awareness of you and how i came to
know who you were and i think it was
probably like i don't know maybe six
months ago was probably from
the joe rogers show i'm not really sure
then i just started like populating my
social media feed like this grilling
weed that was just everywhere i couldn't
get away from it
and i remember watching and i was like
oh yeah even though there were like
comedians who were still funny
i thought they were just all like jimmy
kimmel who
you know like called jared kushner an
[ __ ] or like stephen colbert who like
talk about how donald trump sucks
vladimir putin's penis like just sort of
like a slightly more crude version of
nancy pelosi like that basically has
become what
mainstream comedy in the united states
is now it's complete it's not only
not funny it's pathetic it's just like
all
fear driven it's like just trapped in
these you know like this
most stale and primitive orthodoxies so
i think that it isn't just comedy but
like
every aspect of culture you see it with
films now you see it with
um with art with with everything
that it has all become kind of corrupted
and contaminated
by the trump years in a way that
very few people have been able to escape
and
yeah watching any hollywood you know
like escapist thing like a
an award show or whatever you're going
to hear the same [ __ ] that you hear from
resistance imbeciles on twitter like
there's no escape from it any longer
right it just subsumed everything
d-chained
is the first online platform designed to
make crypto simple because it is simple
crypto that's the one thing i've always
said about it
it's easy to understand easy to grasp
totally makes
sense to everyone that's involved it's
simple
so they're providing easy-to-follow
guidelines investing picks and live
access to their team of
experts that's what i like
there's no shortage of information
online about crypto yet
despite all this information there are
many people who don't know how to get
started what to buy or who to trust
our platform is perfect for investors at
all levels whether you're a complete
beginner or
simply looking for guidance on what to
invest in and best of all
we've created two exclusive offers for
listeners to the tim dylan show
innercircle.com the winkle
for only 4.99 a month cute get our
crypto investing picks weekly newsletter
and crypto playbook crash
course to master the basics the elon
14.99 a month we'll teach you how to
maximize your returns you'll get their
d phi mate simple crash course market
snapshots live
weekly q a with d chains founder ed
mccormick wow that's
that's worth i mean
to make sure you have the information
and guidance you'll need for the next um
bull run so if you're into crypto and
you want to get into crypto and you
don't know where to start you don't know
how it works what they've uh
uh what they've uh created here is a
platform that allows you to
interact to learn to uh
get recommendations about cryptocurrency
um for less than the fee of a single
trade you'll have everything you need
including your expert picks
to start earning visit innercircle.com
and sign up today
innercircle.com and sign up today they
have a team of experts
and those are the people who you'll be
able to
glean uh the information from because
they are
experts in cryptocurrency
um and that's why it's important that
you
deal with them because they are i've
never
i've never learned i did i don't think
that you would say someone's an expert
if they weren't
that's true no no
i believe if you're using the word
expert if you go to the trouble to type
out the word
expert we're looking at some [ __ ]
geniuses i mean
people you shouldn't have access to but
yet you can for 4.99 a month or at 14.99
a month you could get the
founder you know it's a good company
when for 15 a month you can speak to the
founder
if you want that's good
that means they're doing well because
the founder is available
you can just call them up and go what's
what the [ __ ] going on ed
and he'll go you here's the information
guidance you need
for the next bull run you get a live
weekly
q a question and answer session with ed
mccormick
whose time is very valuable that's why
he's giving it away
for 15 a month to people on the internet
who are insane that being said
it's a great way if you don't know about
crypto it's a great way to get in there
innercircle.com if you like my show
uh and you want to support it and also
get into crypto visit innercircle.com
my listeners getting good deals the elon
or the winkle
crypto investing picks you get a
newsletter
you want a sound here's the reality
sound cool
this will be a good way to sound cool it
may get you laid five dollars a month
might get you laid
because somebody might be like hey look
at this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] running his mouth
about cryptocurrency
oh no [ __ ] that guy that could happen
visit innercircle.com and sign up today
this episode is brought to you by psycho
las vegas america's rock and roll
bacchanal
if hunter thompson and lemmy from
motorhead got together to make a music
festival would be psycho you can gamble
swim mosh smoke indoors get wasted get
married
and see 70 plus bands across four
different stages at psycho las vegas
august 20th
through 22nd at mandalay bay resort and
casino good energy there huh
i will of course be performing an hour
of stand-up comedy on august 21st cycle
las vegas will feature performances by
legendary norwegian black metal band
emperor
metal's most recognizable voice glen
danzig down
cannibal corpse pig destroyer thievery
corporation exodus the sword the flaming
lips
dying fetus um
some the wu-tang clan parts of them not
all of them
i hate god spelled eye
and the cambodian psychedelic group
dengue fever
i'm looking forward to it i don't know
anything about any of these bands and i
don't care
but and they they're like in the thing
they go please include if you have
personal experience stories with any of
the bands
yeah i mean cannibal corpse used to go
out together will you [ __ ] shut up
who will you stop i saw marilyn manson
in a uh a hotel room in um
when i was a kid i mean i would not
hotel lobby not a room my parents didn't
bring me to [ __ ] them
it was a lobby i thought it was very
cool
sega las vegas the first post pandemic
indoor music festival with a bunch of
metal heads
that are definitely fully vaccinated
l-o-l taking place at mandalay bay
what could be more fun ah you hear that
i'm getting ready for it my voice is
ready
psycho las vegas man it's a great um
it's a great place to see some uh dark
music and some dark
comedy vivacico.com for tickets viva
psycho.com that's viva psycho.com
it's going to be wild are you a fan of
uh dying fetus
i don't know that band but i like danzig
he's awesome danzig's great
what about uh i hate god spell the white
hate god have it heard i'm looking
forward to it
thievery corporation
oh i think that's the van thievery
corporation oh thievery corporation
yeah it's like an anti-capitalist thing
i guess um
yeah well we'll see tickets and rooms
are limited check out the full lineup
and purchase tickets at viva psycho dot
com that's viva psycho.com
senko las vegas buy the ticket take the
ride
v-i-v-a-p-s-y-c-h-o dot com
now when you julie assange has been in
captivity for about
or he's been held you know hostage for
10 years i think about 10 years
um and he's been psychologically
tortured and
perhaps physically tortured we don't
know no one is calling this out no
no major media that i've seen has really
been
defending julian assange and we know all
the reasons for that we've listed them
in this program already
is there any hope for julian assange is
there any way that
he's released or has he been so broken
at this point that you know even if he
was released it's like they've they've
kind of accomplished what they were
looking to do
i don't know for sure i'm the last time
i
saw julian was in 2018 or
2019 when i went to london and spent
three straight days with him in the
embassy and he at that time was very
lucid very cogent like in good spirits
um but that was before he was
imprisoned he was still at the embassy
although he was looking very pallid i
mean
you know he hasn't been outside in 10
years
right like even prisoners in horrible
american jails get to walk around in the
sun
for like a half an hour an hour a day
julian hasn't he literally hasn't
touched the sun or seen the sun
in 10 years he probably now has in
prison maybe a little bit but when he
was at the embassy he was confined to a
room and a half
almost for a full decade so he was his
health was suffering
um he couldn't exercise he had no son
which is a necessity
you know i the thing that angers me the
most
about the whole situation is you know as
much as the media hates me
when i was doing this snowden reporting
like in 2013 and 2014 and the obama
administration was getting very
threatening i couldn't leave brazil for
like a year
most of the media was on my side and
like defended me why because i was kind
of i had one foot in their world right
like i was at the guardian
one of the oldest newspapers in the west
and then in 2019 and 2020 when i did
this investigative
reporting in brazil that culminated in
the
indictment by the brazilian government
of me the attempt to
criminally prosecute me as bolsonaro the
president of brazil threatened to do for
months
most of the american media almost all of
the american media in fact
manifested in my defense like the new
york times published editorials
you know denouncing it with julian it's
completely different because he's never
really had even one foot
in that media clique and they spent
five years flamboyantly
marching around like planting around as
defenders of press freedom
because trump would like save
some juvenile insult about jim acosta or
post some like mean thing about chuck
todd or wolf blitzer
and they would act like the first
amendment was imperiled and here you
have
an actual grave threat to press freedom
the indictment
that has been unsealed that the biden
administration is now pursuing if it is
if it succeeds it will criminalize
investigative journalism the
relationship that
in fact when the bolsonaro government
tried to criminally prosecute me in 2020
they use that as their model they the
theory that the us government is using
against assange
is the one that the far-right government
in brazil tried to use against me saying
that my relationship between with my
source kind of crossed a line from
passive receipt of information into an
active role in the conspiracy
to steal the information that i was
reporting which is exactly what they're
using against such
so just out of self-interest you would
think american journalists who pretended
for five years to be so
devoted to defending press freedom when
it came to mean tweets
about like blown dry cnn douchebags
would be protesting and demanding biden
drop the prosecution
but they're not they either don't know
about it they don't care about it or
they're cheering it
because they're infantile and what
really what it really is about him
is just it's pure professional jealousy
julian assange has broken more big
stories
in the last decade that all of those
corporate media drones
combined right so
he is what they pretend to be and his
existence kind of holds up a mirror
showing what they really are like why
isn't
the cia and the fbi and the nsa devoted
to imprisoning
like wolf blitzer and jim acosta
or like new york times reporters it's
because they're not [ __ ] threats to
anybody
right they're servants so the fact that
they're doing it to julian
demonstrates who the real danger is who
are the when you look at the
politicians like aoc and people like
that or whether it was bernie sanders or
either the woman with the brain injury
it's forgets marjorie taylor green
who are the who are the people that you
and i don't know that she has a brain
injury i'm speculating that she has some
form of autoimmune disorder but it is
entertaining and i have no problem with
it
i think middle-aged women should go off
a little bit and that's the disagreement
i've had
i think women after they can't have
children should get a little
flighty and nuts you know and a little
offensive yeah quite honestly
i like believe that what do you think's
happening to gay people let's talk about
that for a minute
because it's not fun anymore it's
moralism
i have to tell people how to live it's
very hard for me
to take balls out of my mouth and then
tell people how to live i don't feel
like it's my job
i like going to florida and eating
shrimp but now people want me to go to
libraries and talk to children and
help them realize who they are it's not
my job and i don't care
so what what is this it used to be kind
of fun
and now it's become this really office
politics
bureaucratic uh you know very uh
language driven kind of like it's weird
and strange and
i don't understand it and i don't like
it
it's really sad like whatever is shitty
and cringy
and repressive and weak about liberal
politics
it finds its like lowest point like it's
zenith
in gay institutional politics right
which is really sad because like we're
basically the same age i think you're
like 5 or 10 years older than i am
obviously how old are you
when what how old are you
27 how old are you 16.
so you're wrong yeah so you're right i
stand corrected so like i'm a little
older than you
yes i know you know like when gay
politics
was subversive by necessity harvey mills
radical yes interesting yeah and like
larry kramer
activism yes andrew sullivan to a degree
as well yeah i mean andrew sullivan was
kind of like
ironically the sort of like trying to be
the catholic conservative
you need to get a conservative that's
why i like caitlyn jenner you need
someone
you need someone in the community that
just really likes the country club
yeah well and you also want like
diversity right like that's the whole
point of a liberation movement is not to
be
constrained in captivity but to be free
in your expression of whatever you do
but what it but ultimately the politics
were more radical and interesting
you know we kind of went from like larry
kramer to [ __ ] pete bootage
right you know that's like for me the
trajectory yes but also
the the what's really happened for me
like in terms of the you know you're
talking to the reversals before on like
foreign policy and imperialism with
rachel maddow and culture or whatever
it's also taken place culturally you
know
when i was growing up the people who
wanted to control
private behavior and culture was the
right you know like jerry falwell and
the moral majority
like the transgression came from the
left like sinead o'connor ripping up a
picture of the pope
on saturday night live and so the left
always was
the culturally transgressive movement of
liberation that came out of the 60s
obviously as well like the summer of
love right like hippies and all of that
the free speech movement as well this is
completely reversed
the cultural left in the united states
has a longer list of rules for how you
can date how you can [ __ ]
how you can like feel sexual attraction
for somebody
than the [ __ ] pope has with his
encyclicals
like all this like formula for who you
can date in ages and like
what you have to do and they want to
control everything everything is abuse
everything is harassment
it is it's like watching this mirror
image
where they have all become this like
highly
repressive movement that
is unrecognizable to me except with
reference to what
the evangelical and christian right was
in the 1980s right it's all become and
even the pushback to the pushback is
boring i i don't like i'm like also it's
like
you know trans women weightlifters i
mean i know that's an issue but
i can't care about that on either side i
just don't care
about the olympics and i i don't care
about any one
man or woman who competes in the
olympics and i'm not saying it's not a
nice thing to do but i just
personally i don't care i find the
olympics to be sort of a large waste of
time
for me personally i know that other
people attach meaning to it and that's
fine but for me i don't
care at all if you know i don't care
that uh you know but
but it has gotten to this very weird
point it's just exhaustive all of it's
exhaustive
the left isn't the right is exhaustive
it it you just get to a point now where
nothing is new we have the same
conversations in a circular
pattern over and over again that's why
trump was sort of exciting because at
least
there were there was this there were
these new conversations happening now
they were all insane
the people with q and on were clearly
lost their minds and
russiagate as well what do you make of
of
of how we come out of this pandemic how
do you think
personal freedoms and and and kind of
this
alliance we see now between big tech and
big pharma
and health policy and and these very
powerful wealthy people
like bill gates how do we emerge from
this pandemic
uh do we emerge much like we the same as
before
or are we now kind of on the road to
um a technocracy where
decisions about your own body decisions
about your own health
decisions about all kinds of things
sexual freedoms
are all going to be uh somehow
uh strongly suggested and or enforced
by government policy
i mean i think the the covet pandemic
is clearly the most transformative event
of our lives you know the only thing
that probably competes with it is the
911 attack
but i would say it it's
probably gonna be much more enduring and
consequential because it operates on so
many other levels
you know i remember going back uh to
like march or
april of 2020 when the lockdowns first
began and we were all socially isolated
and told we couldn't leave our homes and
all those celebrities were saying stay
at home
the idea at the time was people have
forgotten this
you just have to do that for a few weeks
the idea is you have to flatten the
curve
right like you have to prevent the
health care system from being
overburdened
and collapsing so you want to make sure
the covet cases kind of stream out in a
way that's manageable so you just stay
home for a few weeks maybe a couple
months
and then that will enable the healthcare
system to gain its footing and then but
then of course like the lockdowns
quickly turned into something
much more protracted than that and back
in you know
march and april of 2020 it was obvious
to me
there was like a a taboo you know like
trump was saying
and i think boris johnson was as well uh
before he almost
died of covid that look you know yeah we
want to make sure people don't get
coveted but like locking people in their
homes for
months at a time is going to have its
own huge cost it's going to destroy the
economy
right which makes people sick it
shortens people's lifespan it causes
people to be depressed it causes mental
health illness
there was already huge increases in
mental health pathology in the west
every indicia of like suicide depression
anxiety disorders addiction alcoholism
everyone was already skyrocketing before
the pandemic happens then you take
everybody and you you kind of exacerbate
all of the deprivations that modern
society is imposing on people the lack
of connectivity the lack of purpose we
don't have like
churches anymore or synagogues or labor
unions or like we all live in these tiny
little
right isolated hovels right where we
we're with
with really unfulfilling jobs that's
what's causing these mental health
pathologies people can't get married
until they're like 40
if they get married at all um
they have to live with their parents so
this exacerbated everything
and i interviewed two health uh mental
health experts johan hari and andrew
solomon
and they both said this refusal
to take into account the cost on the
other side of the ledger
from lockdown's isolation and the like
is
mind-boggling because probably it's
going to be at least as significant as
the number of deaths or
debilitating effects from kovid and no
one wanted to hear that you weren't
allowed to do anything other than
singularly focus on the danger of covid
and it reminded me a lot of like the
first few years after 9 11
you know the reason why mostly i began
writing was because there was this
obsession on safetyism like oh my god
we're so scared of terrorists
we're ready to dismantle our entire
system of government and our culture and
our
constitutional reporter in order to
protect against it when the whole time
even at the height of terrorist activity
in like 2002 2003
the chances that you're gonna die of in
the terrorist attack if you were an
american was less than
literally the chance that you would die
by getting hit by lightning or like
going out to dinner and eating some
contaminated food and dying of it
it was always radically exaggerated but
by forcing everybody
by scaring the [ __ ] out of everybody
basically it turned americans into this
like completely submissive
acquiescent population so that
conservatives who like four years
earlier were like
don't comment onto our land you know
we're gonna uh use our guns to
you know we're like meekly taking off
their [ __ ] shoes at airports and
doing whatever they
were told you saw this like compliance
that came from this collective fear
and exactly the same thing happened with
coven but
so much worse not only did people just
stay at home for a year like my kids you
know
missed an entire year of school like
think about what that's going to do to
you know hundreds of millions of kids
around the world
um but also tim you know i think what it
really did is it centralized
power in the hands of already
like you know basically omnipotent
institutions of authority so that
you were no longer allowed to even
question the pronouncements of
balchi or the world health organization
or you would be banned from the internet
right everybody was happy with that
everybody was fine with that even though
they proved so often to be wrong
and then you had these corporate giants
like amazon
and google and you know walmart
that consolidated their power so much
more as small businesses just died
everywhere and so now the whole country
is like a country of serfs and renters
who work for like a handful of tiny
corporations with no competition
everybody's enslaved to these like
monopolistic authorities
and has been trained to obey authority
more than ever
because they've been convinced that it's
the only way they can survive
so politically culturally
psychologically and in every other way i
think the
enduring effects of this are going to be
much
deeper and much uh longer than people
realize right now
zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein
only four net grams of carbs
140 calories is surfing
it's keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free
low carb gmo free
you can build your own box or get a
variety
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter stop
being fat blueberry and cinnamon are
also new get a [ __ ]
promo code magicspoon.com tim dillon
what are you gonna
do cereal is good for everybody
you can be healthy and eat like [ __ ]
you know what i'm talking about it's
magic spoonfuls magicspoon.com you know
what it is
it's a sugar cereal without any sugar
you know what it is high quality
sweeteners like monk fruit you know what
it is
i love cereal but the best thing about
cereal
is that it tastes good and the worst
thing about it is that it makes you
a fat piece of [ __ ] but
what if i have a cold what if
cereal that you ate
that you liked was actually healthy for
you
how great is that that's what this is
it's cereal but it's healthy for you
even if you put it in your ass
if you eat it through your ass it still
has zero grams of sugar
truly like if you if you let it dissolve
in your ass
and get the nutrients that way it will
still have
four net grams of carbs
magicspoon.com timdillonmagicsplin.com
tim dillon remember to get your next
delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
tim dillon and use the code tim dillon
to save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode i met the guy
uh from sheath underwear robert patron
and we love sheath underwear of course
it can be used as bathing suits
underwear it's got a pouch to support
your uh junk
and he was such a nice guy he was very
nice
i was shocked when i met
him and he he had a real
good spirit about everything because he
essentially told me that i was right
about everything that i had said
but he didn't want his wife or kids to
know but he pulled me aside and he said
i've killed
so many innocent civilians children
women men
animals dogs cats he goes i've just
killed everybody guys i don't really
bring it up
but he goes i did it and then he looked
at me and said i wish i could do it
again i want to do it again he goes i
wish i could do it again
sheath underwear dot com promo code tim
to save 20
he was very nice he brought his whole
family in there
in denver you met him um yeah he lives
in colorado he has a militia
in colorado he is a militia he's getting
ready for the race war sheath underwear
dot com
use code tim 20 he says he's starting
with his family and training them
he hopes to get other recruits uh for
the race war
sheath underwear.com um
he said he's been preparing for it for
years but america is finally catching up
in his words so it's very exciting
it's very exciting he said he's putting
them through you know kind of a regular
kind of like basic training
and then getting them like you know
doing weapons training and getting them
proficient
in you know to different types of
uh hand-to-hand combat as well as kind
of more of a strategic
assault plans for um
the upcoming race war again according to
um the owner of sheath underwear dot com
which i would absolutely go and buy the
underwear
sheath underwear dot com you use code
tim to save 20
uh his wife is a lovely person she also
uh is planning for the race war
she's cooking and
getting little little lunch lunches
ready for everyone
so that they can take them she's also a
violent psychopath with a gun i don't
want to ever
i don't want to make women feel like
they're not but she is she did we talked
about that she was cooking and kind of
um just putting putting together uh
packages for the
for the for the boys to have while
they're on the road
cleansing is what she said it's her
words not mine
sheath underwear.com no seriously they
do love comedy these people i met them
they love comedy it's great underwear
if you like the show you want to support
us
support them support people that like
comedy and defend comedy
sheath underwear dot com used promo code
tim
to save 20 do you ever look back
at events like 911 where we took 15
pages or 17 pages out of the 911
commission report
uh to protect saudi arabia and things
like that
and we you know people on the 911
commission have said that it was set up
to fail and bush and cheney
would only testify in a in a closed
session together sitting next to each
other
um do you think there's anything more
that we should know about that day
and i'm not suggesting that it was like
um this you know a
massive conspiracy but is there
something do you think
later on down the line we will find out
things about that day that
surprise us or enlighten us to a degree
i mean you know i think you kind of have
to pick and choose your battles
as like a public person right yeah
there's certain things that you fight
for and then other things you say
i'm going to leave that alone right
right we all like find that energy and
whatever but here's what i will say is
that
why is it tell me someone tell me why it
is i've been asking this question for
years and no one has an answer
that 60 years
after the assassination of john kennedy
60 years most of the files
in the cia about that event are still
classified
like we even though everyone involved is
dead right
what conceivable rationale is there for
continuing to conceal that and you go
back throughout you know all those
assassinations that you mentioned about
the 60s even into the 50s there are
things
the reason is is because this permanent
national security state that you had
asked me about earlier that got
constructed in the wake of the us
victory in world war ii
and that was designed to at least
nominally combat
communism in the soviet union which also
became strengthened after
its victory in world war ii that
it has done so many things to
that that would shock people if they
learned about it
that it would shatter the foundations of
people's confidence and trust
in current institutions today even
though
all those people are long dead so i
don't put anything past
the us government in all of these big
events
you know there are like why don't we
know whether the fbi
had informants in the three groups they
claim are behind the january sixth
riot the three percenters the oath
keepers and the proud boys it's
inconceivable that they did it right of
course they were monitoring those groups
we know that the
leader of the proud boys had already
served as an informant to the fbi
these questions just nobody wants the
answers to these questions
because once you start digging too deep
into those questions
it becomes impossible to function almost
you have to
and me and joe talk about some yeah me
and rogan talked about it where we said
you look at even these you know antifa
riots you saw cop cars that were just
left there you saw pallets of bricks on
the side of the road like
it did seem like uh you know you with
the capital right you saw a cop opening
the gate to let people in it does seem
like
at the very least uh there are forces
that want these things to happen that
want chaos that want these things to
descend quickly into chaos
and that the result of that will be
people that are more compliant
um and and you look at that and even
with you know the boston marathon
bombing
the fbi knew who these two guys were and
russian intelligence said we told you
who they were
then the fbi came out and admitted we
knew who they were they were allowed to
travel back and forth to dagestan
you know so there is this idea that they
were potential and also
they also went and like interviewed one
of the closest friends
killed him um and killed him like yeah
anyone there were like
six of them and they invented some
[ __ ] story about why they did that
yeah which is probably they just didn't
want him talking
and they just whacked him just got rid
of him it's like a mafia state
yeah and i mean you know you look at you
know
if you look at if what are the effects
of january 6 the effects of january 6
are that
the capitol police got two billion
dollars more
because the democrats voted to give them
more
there's a new domestic war on terror
there's a new war on terror the same one
that we had for the last 20 years after
9 11 but this time directed
inward domestically at quote domestic
extremists
all of those agencies right like who
else scares americans putin doesn't
scare americans isis is gone al qaeda is
old
they're all like old villains on their
last legs you need
new scary threats in order to justify
the
continuous growth and bureaucratic power
and and budgets of these institutions
and now you have it you have right wing
extremists white supremacists whatever
you want to call them very similar do
you know
people forget that like after the
oklahoma city bombing in 1995
which also has its own course the fbi
knew and all that
immediately arose a very similar
narrative like on the cover of every
magazine time magazine newsweek goes to
where it was like
white supremacist militias are this huge
danger
and this is when the internet was first
starting to
emerge as a real force in american life
and the clinton administration's primary
demand in the wake of oklahoma city
was to have back door access to all
encryption so that nobody could ever use
the internet to communicate in a way
that was off limits or out of reach from
the u.s government each each one of
these incidents
always strengthens the power centers
that
are constantly involved in some way and
you could just write it off and say
maybe they're just incompetent they just
kind of know in advance about all of
them but they don't figure out what's
going on they don't know how to stop it
or you can like look at the history of
what these institutions actually do
and take a more jaded view of what's
more likely
right that some of these events are
being actively encouraged because of the
consequences and who they benefit are
are people like aoc
do you think she gets i already kind of
see it happening where she gets folded
into kind of the mainstream
of american political culture and then
just kind of becomes
everybody's favorite girl boss
she you know it's funny uh when she was
running
against joe crowley in that primary in
when no one who knew who she was one of
my colleagues at the intercept ryan
graham who like has his pulse on
his finger on the pulse of like the
left-wing of democratic
politics the left-wing flank i remember
he like
emailed me he said hey you know there's
this candidate i think you're really
gonna love her
um and you know she could really use
your voice like supporting her and i
went and looked and i was like she was
saying all this like radical stuff and
it was during the
war with israel and gaza like one of the
ten thousand wars but it was an outbreak
of violence at the time and the israelis
were shooting
gazans at the border just over a fence
like just randomly shooting at them and
she went on twitter running for congress
in new york and said it's time that
my party the democratic party stopped
overlooking the human rights abuses of
israel and i was like all right
she sounds good right so i interviewed
her
and if you go and watch that interview
that i did with her it went viral at the
time like that's when people started
really
knowing who she was you won't recognize
her
like it's a completely unrecognizable
person the person that i interviewed and
then
championed from the person that she's
become
and it reminds me you know like i i was
friends with all those msnbc hosts i
used to be very good friends with rachel
maddow
like when she was on air america and
then even when she first got her msnbc
show same with chris hayes
and in 2011 chris hayes wrote a book
before he got his msnbc show called
twilighty the elites
and the main thesis of the book is that
elite america has failed it has no more
claim valid claim to authority and his
argument was
this concept he called cognitive capture
which is that
elite institutions have become so
perfectly constructed
that anyone who enters them and immerses
themselves in them
inevitably not likely or usually but
inevitably
will become co-opted by them no matter
how well intentioned you are when you
enter them no matter how resistant you
think you are to their pieties
the reward system that they have it's
like a perfectly constructed
psychological
[ __ ] of your brain right that no human
being can resist
it's just been perfected over so long
and i remember i asked chris in that
interview that i did with him
well you're about to go have an msnbc
show what are you doing to prepare
yourself
to inoculate yourself against this and
he's like i don't know i haven't really
thought about it and you can see the
effects of the fact that
he was telling the truth so you put aoc
in washington
and you tell her hey you know
you want to be on this committee that'll
give you like a lot of
like social media viral moments where
you get to like
snap at some like banking executive or
whatever
we'll put you on that committee as long
as you shut the [ __ ] up about
the attacks you're doing on nancy pelosi
and
our donors and as long as you've i you
know i'll tell you
this is actually what has changed my
view you know my husband
is a congressman here in brazil he ran
for city council of rio general in 2016
and one and then ran for the federal
congress 2018 now he's a congressman
so i see it from the inside what happens
like he was raised in this you know like
really poor slum in in rio de janeiro
his friends lived there exactly
exactly very good there's people that
aren't worldly
but i am and every now and then i want
to let people know
do you ever by the way i'm gonna let you
continue but have you ever uh
encountered the brazilian wandering
spider there fenetrius pharah
yes we lived in this like uh
kind of you know like forest area of rio
on the top of a mountain and
frequently those things are [ __ ]
terrifying and would
enter our house and um i would have to
call somebody
who was not my husband or myself to go
kill them
um all right continue with the concept
yeah so anyway so he grew up in a
fabella
he like he like actually you know he
like entered politics because he
actually cares it's cute
he like yeah seriously he doesn't think
of it as a career he like really wants
to help people's
lives improve or whatever so he'll have
like a bill
that will like allocate like i don't
know like say a million dollars to build
some community center
in the like favela so these kids right
who are like eight and ten have things
to do and don't get recruited into drug
gangs like actual things that will help
you right
and then he'll go to the like the
scumbag leaders of the congress who
control
what gets on the floor and i'll be like
can you help me get this
you know bill on the floor and they'll
say to him yeah we'll let your bill come
up for a vote and we'll even like
make sure it passes but we need you to
make sure that you and your
faction vote for this corrupt giveaway
to our funders and lobbyists like we'll
do a deal
you vote for this and then you're
suddenly in the position of like
do i stand on principle right you know
and just say go [ __ ] yourself and then
get nothing for the
people who sent me there to help improve
their lives and i get to feel good about
myself but do nothing
or do i make that compromise and then
like the more you make that compromise
the more you get sucked into that system
and before you know it you no longer
distinguish between what's really the
compromise and what's not what's the way
around it it just seems like human
nature is kind of inherently flawed
and that no matter what system you set
up um
you're gonna have something like this
you know i mean you could get public
money out of politics i mean good luck
that seems like a good idea but i mean
then you'll just have
you know the epstein and the jazlane
you'll have like there'll always be kind
of ways
there'll always be things people want
that they can't have that are provided
to them there's some illicit
uh and they'll always be controlled you
know when you look at the epstein
situation
how many elected officials are
blackmailed bribed
owned controlled you know with sex
with drugs with things that they did
cheating on taxes
businesses they had years ago like how
much how big
of a scope do you think that is
yeah i mean it's hard to say right
that's one of the things that never got
investigated because of his unfortunate
and tragic suicide in prison
yes and you know
i think um you know human nature if you
just look at history
like human nature is a really ugly thing
right
and so it's almost impossible to
construct a politics or
human institutions that aren't plagued
by these kinds of pathologies
on the other hand we do as humans also
have this kind of
capacity for compassion and empathy
because we're
political and social animals we do have
a kind of better side that can be
appealed to
so i don't know i i've kind of come to
the conclusion
that what humans really do need is is
leadership like
strong charismatic people who they
follow
who are gonna be imperfect who are gonna
do dirty deals because that's just the
nature of how you wield power
but who just on balance are gonna make
things somewhat better and i think
that's the most of what you can ask for
and hope for
yeah it's a very rationalist view do you
like brazil will you
stay oh yeah like the first time i ever
came here
um it was i i got here
like at night i woke up the next morning
i was in rio
with my partner at the time and i told
him i was like after we walked around
for two hours i said i seriously like
i'm concerned that anytime we have
an opportunity to travel i'm never going
to want to see any other part of the
world i'm always going to want to come
back here
right it just like spoke to me it like
resonated with my soul
and now like you know we're we have a
life here like my husband has a
political career we have two
sons who are both brazilian very
brazilian um
and yeah i love it as much as i ever
have it's like
it's just a very vibrant fascinating
eclectic like culturally
like really um
innovative country like there's really
nothing else like it it's like austin
no um that's a joke for my listeners but
uh we're we're in a dump we're leaving
um
joe rogan convinced us to move here to a
swamp um
do you have you ever gone to the amazon
podcaster
he's he's in fear factor guy he told us
to all move here and then
we came here and it's like there's like
two restaurants and they suck
everyone's they're just tech people
tech people they don't even it's like
tech people they don't care about
culture they're just eating like
macadamia nuts
and and sitting there in their estates
trying to figure out how to choke the
remaining freedoms we have out of us and
they don't care and they
you know they did it to the the bay area
where it's like you know it's just kind
of a
boring you know who cares and the cities
all go to [ __ ]
because the resources are sucked out and
you know given to
condo developers so they can build you
know um you know high-rises with
floating bathtubs
and then you have all these problems
what do you what do you make of like
have you been in the amazon the amazon's
always fascinated me i've always wanted
to go there
i mean i haven't spent you know lots of
time there in a way that like i can
say anything meaningful about it besides
what you read about it i mean i've been
there twice
for a couple of events um
but yeah like it's just the kind of it's
like what it makes you realize is that
you know they're they're people who live
in the amazon who are tribes that have
no
contact with the outside world yes that
are just very
pristine and and and discarded from the
matrix
i saw one of them on tick tick-tock
where is
now are these people just completely
uh and they'll be killed right with
diseases because they have no immunity
well i mean kovid started entering
because one of the things that most of
our government is doing
one of the ways peopleson r1 was he got
funded by the
like lumber industry and right aggregate
businesses that want to
cut down the entire amazon and sell it
all off for profit
so they're constantly invading the
amazon
they don't give a [ __ ] about the
indigenous people who live there and
they did they like one of the things
they did was bring kovit to
a lot of those indigenous tribes that as
you say don't really have they have no
health care system and they
really don't have much of an immunity
because they've been inbred for so long
not to need it because they're not
exposed to tons of bacteria and viruses
like the way we are
so they had a much higher death rate um
a lot of these tribes that from kova
than
non-indigenous people yeah and that's
unfortunate
are you planning on making any trips to
the united states are you going
are you working on a new book are you
what's the next
phase what's the next thing for you are
you gonna start a podcast to build a
social media empire are you gonna be an
influencer
where where do you think the next
journey takes you
well i'm doing some modeling obviously
that's always been a big part of what
i've done and
it fulfills yeah yeah i know i've seen
you at shoots yes
um no well i was like i said i was i was
supposed to be in austin
literally right now we would have taken
you for dinner it's gonna be the first
proven how bad it was i know yeah yeah
that would have been great um but i'm
gonna i'm gonna be i just had to cancel
for logistical reasons that are too
boring and annoying to go into
but i'm gonna be there a little bit yeah
i'm gonna start traveling again i don't
miss traveling
um you know i'm i'm my sub stack is has
you know
excited me it's been a big success and
um
i'm i'm also gonna there's like i'm
really interested in
the only things i'm interested in are
things that exist outside the binary
like outside the matrix that
outside of that like dreary left right
fighting yeah those are the only things
i listen to those are the only things
i'm interested in they're the only
places i'm going the reason why i go on
tucker carlson's show
is because i feel like that is an
example of like something that's
politically and ideologically heterodox
um it's why i think joe's show has
been successful yeah you know um
and you know like crystal and sagar that
whole world that's where you're
interested so
i'm gonna i'm about to actually go to a
new platform i'm gonna stay on subset
but i'm going to do a kind of new video
platform that's not youtube
that i'm going to announce soon where
i'm going to do a bunch of like video
programming and
bring some people with me we're going to
do a bunch of interesting stuff
um yeah so it's just it's so funny
because when i left the intercept i did
it very precipitously it was the thing i
created i was there for seven years
and it provided me a ton of security and
i like quit in 24 hours
with no planning and it was just the
best [ __ ] thing that ever happened
like just the emancipation
not just like not no longer needing to
be captive to an institution but just
psychologically
you know like there's never a moment
anymore when i think
maybe i can't say this maybe i can't
talk about this because of
the need to appease that world because
i've just not only cut myself off from
that world but then burned it
down to the ground as i left so
yeah i mean i'm just very excited by you
know the
opportunity to there's like a growing
ecosystem of people
who want to do interesting things yes
and i just want to keep
being part of that well you're you're
welcome here anytime joe loves you and
we'll well
you know that's an open invitation like
people like you are very important
they're rare and for me as a comedian
funny is always found in the gray areas
uh in the the the uh you know the
non-binary whatever you were saying the
non-heterodox
uh not in the non-binary that's actually
they they don't love funny over there
but i mean in the political non-binary
in the
in the in the spaces between things
because i think that's where you get the
greater truths right i think the
the goal of any comedian or a journalist
is to like hit
a harder truth than the one that's right
there for the taking i think the one
that's right there for the taking
um is shallow and if you're good at your
what you do you're trying to reach for
that deeper thing
but where can people follow you if they
want to support your sub stack
yeah so it's just we've been trying to
get katie herzog
unsuccessfully de-platformed from sub
stackers she called me a fat goon
and i've written letters and we want her
off every social media
katie herzog who's america's uh final
lesbian the last lesbian
that we have but uh that's hate speech
fat goon
is hate speech all right continue i'm
gonna get her i'm gonna get
i'm gonna get her kicked off for you
thank you she actually she actually got
me trending
on twitter for 48 hours as a transphobe
because she wrote an article
about how lesbians are disappearing
because they're all becoming trans
men yes and i cited that in connection
with my discussion of this new gallup
poll showing
that like everyone in the universe now
identifies as like queer and unbiased
yeah
none of them are gay none of them are
gay none of them are having sex with
anyone it's primarily online
it's amazing they're like obsessed with
sexual identity
and yet despised sex it's just the most
asexualized creation
even though it's all constructed around
this correct identity i know and we love
candies
we do have apparently abusive we love
katie she got me she got
she got me like trending she didn't
[ __ ] trend i trended even though like
i was only just citing her article
anyway so i'm totally behind whatever
anti-katie herzog yes perfect you have
it we'll help with that whenever i can i
want to be a platformer i want to like
um ruin her life really so people can
find me at greenwald.subscribe
obviously on twitter i'm going to be on
the tim dillon show a lot i'm just going
to invite myself on periodically
i think i pretty much invite myself on
this time um
yeah so i'll be around yes um say
say hello to my friend ida is such a
huge glenn greenwald fan she's so upset
that you're gay she would move to brazil
and live with you uh
so just shout out ida say sh to tavakoli
she's
persian she's always talking about the
iranian revolution as if you could shout
her out that would be
very very cool for her just say hello
there you go see you guys
there it is and one of these dogs just
before i let you go
i mean why don't you put the colors on
them that they
uh that uh stuns them and shocks them
and shakes them or drug them
i would i would sooner put a shock
collar on you joe than i would on i mean
a
damn than i would on them um and
i've paid good money to have a shot
caller put on me
uh well i know i say that because i
heard you liked it
yeah the only reason why i would do it
glenn greenwald at sub stack go
find him very good we we we appreciate
you coming on
thank you very much for doing this good
talking to you tim
thank you